our country Nigeria Republic is a member
of the ecowas and uh in the protocol of
the ecowas there is the possibility of
using uh violence against
any power that is trying to use violence
to seize the power in in skechos country
so uh it's not a matter of if we support
or not but we are
saying that if Echo has tried to use
violence it it is not illegal because
there are these protocol
that are in the ecowas
Amendments Frenchies in contact with one
of our leaders who is trying to
negotiate with the Junta that's all we
know and that's all I know but we don't
have any connection with the French
about their military intervention